brian cranston looks like jim carrey
impersonating matthew mcconaughey
all right all right all righty then
i bet anne hathaway has a weird vagina
well you'll never know russ d dillon
oh that's this is just wrong shaq's
penis is kevin hart
maisie williams looks like a very young
grandma
gina davis is a real man's man
tiffany haddish has a big ass mouth you
can't bring ratchet ass [ __ ] like her
nowhere just shut up
well you know what why don't you shut up
with your 14 followers but thank you for
introducing me to them
i hate ted dansom he's got a face i'd
like to take a
a dawn
[Music]
is that a word i might be wondering
why that woman got no titties
they're here they're here don't worry i
bet jennifer lawrence gives really
unenthusiastic
how did they know
is kamel nanjiani's
multiple colors
yes
every shade of your mom's lipstick
and her butthole
if i said it once i've said it 100 times
andy garcia
david blaine looks like his voice is
putting his face to sleep
john rickers looks like yoda
when it's paltrow you ugly ass big bird
looking [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up
ben addict cumberbatch what a dead
[Music]
rob lowe looks like skin cancer
what in the
is up with amy poehler's face
[ __ ] looks like she survives a nuclear
blast
kelly ripa is kind of amazing when you
think about how hard it must be to
balance that huge head on a tiny body
selena gomez is on the radio right now
is there a volume lower than mute
sorry
lol yo will ferrell
dumb
[Music]
oh maybe you're dumb
allison janney looks like a substitute
teacher everyone hates
well you
i bet the john lithgow's ball sack looks
exactly like his
face my face is not complimented but my
ball sack is
dr phil
why don't you shut the
ball-headed big mouth hillbilly
jennifer garner looks like a duck's
vagina literally a duck's
[Music]
there are people who think julia roberts
is hot
her gigantic mouth
looks like
it will devour an elephant in one bite
elizabeth banks is a [ __ ]
daniel radcliffe is one of god's most
unattractive creations since the
aardvark
sofia vergara sounds like she has a in
her mouth i hate hearing her talk
what's wrong with having my mouth
chloe moretz or whatever her stupid name
is
looks like my
seriously she is not decent looking
whatsoever
you must have a really bleach
stop chris pratt
jennifer aniston is what happens when a
bag of flour gets its big break
because it's like i'm a bag of flour so
funny
jim parsons looks like a ventriloquist
dummy that came to life
to become a sex offender oh
kit harrington is a pretty terrible jon
snow
in the show he seems like a big [ __ ]
with a stupid look on his face hashtag
bad casting
look at me i'm julia louis-dreyfus i was
on seinfeld the show about white people
in new york eating pickles and man
you [ __ ]
sarah paulson you [ __ ] i have mixed
feelings about you right now guess what
mother
flick i have mixed feelings about you
too
yo at kevin underscore kneeling you suck
fat balls
that is true
if you change the i in ana ferris's last
name to a t you get on a
farts interesting
you chris rock
you are on grownups too
[Music]
well if you lost all your money in
divorce you'd be on grownups 2-2
tom arnold you're an inspiration to all
fat dumps who love cocaine and who love
to fat disgusting chicks
my hairy penis thanks you
you're welcome
i hope you all have a great weekend
except you lisa kudrow
if an alien landed here and demanded a
famous person to eat
i drive straight to adam sandler's house
with a net now
is
[Music]
[Music]
it's actually sweet
can it be my turn to punch andy dick
until there's bones in his stool
will ferrell is a fool
that's a compliment that one i can tell
is a compliment
i'm a [ __ ] fool
look at me yo i'm a fool
thank you
thank you i just cut a fart that smells
so bad they added david spade as a
supporting character
that's not bad i actually auditioned for
that i didn't know if i got it
i bet zendaya's feet smell like funyuns
let's check shall we
nope smells like success to me
why does ryan gosling always look like
he's trying to squeeze a fart out
without making any noise
he's also spiderman
dakota johnson has some serious nose
happening cool
jordana brewster is the next meryl
streep
if meryl streep was the worst actress in
the world
[Music]
i could take a picture of a piece of
in my toilet and it would be a better
movie than garden state
someone just told me i smiled like
michael keaton and i don't know if i
should take one million selfies or put a
gun in my mouth
i'd put a gun in your mouth
joel mchale
is a huge d-bag
oh you couldn't spell douche you have
140 characters
couldn't spell douche i get it
malcolm in the middle more like mushy in
the middle
lose some weight heisenberg
i've got a good chuckle over that one
i'm coming after you
tx grizz
has zac efron ever been in a film where
he didn't play a total douche i've never
seen one of his films i'm just judging
by his face
it's a good thing ray romano is funny
because his face looks like a dump i
took today
you know i'm not on twitter so i can't
respond to uh to golf guy 127. here's
what you should do go to my website and
join go to the bottom of the page just
keep hitting agree agree agree and when
you get to you hit accept
too bad they don't give an oscar for
blowing ass because matt damon would win
every year
go buy another zoo and live in it born i
dead
no disrespect to ben affleck
are you wearing yoga pants
no
he's wearing yoga pants